comment section of this one's gonna be a
nightmare isn't it
[Applause]
[Music]
Doctor Who new episodes continue when we
reach episode three of series 12 orphan
55 I was both excited and nervous about
this one because it was written by Ed
Hine now at haim also wrote it takes you
away which was my favorite episode of
series 11 so I was excited but I was
also inherently nervous because the last
time I let myself get really excited
because someone who wrote an episode I
loved to have written a new episode it
was the old gaming because I really
loved the doctor's wife and that episode
was nightmare and silver so I was trying
very hard not to not to get overexcited
and the end result is decent for the
most part yes we'll get to the thing
that everybody is losing their friggin
minds over we'll get there
hold off on it stick a pin in it but
it's it's just decent there's nothing
particularly exceptional about it there
are a fair number of little touches that
I like but then there are other little
things that I don't enjoy and the
overall plot is pretty standard Doctor
Who it's it's a slightly more harrowing
version of the base underseas thing you
know they're in a confined space things
are trying to break in they shake it up
slightly by actually having them leave
the confined space and and try and
travel and rescue somebody for a bit so
like that's a slight break up but that's
that's not a serious shake up the
overall thing of we're in here bad
things out there they're trying to get
in just shifts to a smaller area for the
duration in which they're in the
van so you know that it doesn't really
massively structurally change it at a
fundamental level it just sort of
overall just gives it a slightly
different feel for a little bit of time
as I said there are some some good
moments some good subtle bits I I really
liked what went on between Ryan and
Bella for a number of reasons some of
which I'm actually gonna end up
referencing again when we get to that
thing that we set aside that we're gonna
come back to and I like the way that
they make so little connections with
each other I like that there's an
instant bond and then we learn over time
that they've got a bit more in common
than maybe they would have expected and
I think the two performers had really
good chemistry yes again does not get a
lot to do Graham doesn't get very much
to do either but I I don't know I find
Graham just has a a little bit more of
an assertive personality so I noticed
him more when he pops back in where is
he as I actually can tend to forget what
scene she was in sometimes and I feel
really bad saying that because again I
don't think the problems the actor I
don't even necessarily think the problem
is the character and parently they just
don't seem to be taking the time to
figure out something to do with her and
that it that was an issue last series
and it's really starting to become
glaring at this point I like that the
episode starts and they're commenting on
how the doctor has been kinda grumpy
lately I like that we're picking up the
emotional place that she was in at the
end of the previous episode and not
immediately treating it like
everything's fine a witch doctor who
does have a tendency to do I recently
wrapped up my rewatch of series six and
there are a number of episodes
immediately following very intense
emotional episodes that are very light
and bouncy and it's like feelings they
should be a little bit more lasting
damage with what's going on
little bit more acknowledgement and I
think just opening in and having that
established with her that that works
decently well the the rest of the
supporting cast there find the guy with
the green hair and his kid they were
okay it was it was a dynamic that was
very easy to track where it was gonna go
because the dad kept dismissing the help
from the Sun even though the Sun clearly
knew what he was doing better than the
dad did and you're like okay this is
just eventually going to culminate in
the father having to admit that the son
knows this stuff better and there'll be
a little bonding thing or whatever and
that's pretty much what happened so but
it was okay it was fine it was the
elderly couple which I have mixed
feelings about like in theory in
principle I kind of like the idea that
the person who they're going to save is
somebody that if you were to sit down
and come up with the reasons to save
somebody
most people go look he would the guy was
on an oxygen tank anyway he didn't have
a lot of time left we're not gonna risk
any but everybody else to go save him
but I kind of like that they do for the
same reason that while I take issue with
some of the things that happened in the
10th doctor's regeneration story I do
like that ultimately he sacrifices
himself to save will even though welcome
self says I'm an old man please don't
because it's still worth saving it's
still a life so I do kind of like that
at least in principle in practice I
cannot remember the woman's name now but
the the older woman she just I think the
problem is the script only gave her
basically fear and borderline hysteria
about getting Bernie back and almost
nothing else to play at all so it makes
it
rather one note I will say though I did
really there was something very
unsettling about from the outside of the
van
Bernie's voice going I just I need to
ask you two questions first is will you
marry me the second is can somebody
please shoot me it's yeah that that was
kind of a oh wow
so like madan paper better than I like
it in reality I think just because
largely of how one-dimensional the woman
was written to be frustratingly when it
comes to Bella and Kane there were a lot
of interesting nuances they were largely
in the performance both those actresses
brought little touches to the to the way
that they played their scenes either
with each other or talking about each
other especially Bella like there was a
lot that that actress brought to the
table at the point of which she was told
that Kane didn't make it there was a lot
of subtlety in what she did and she
conveys a lot while saying very little I
was quite impressed with that
I suppose we should talk about the
monsters but you talk about the drags I
I'm slightly frustrated with them
because it's a cool design
and in the first half of the episode
when they're trying to bust in or some
of them have even gotten in to the dome
they look really good but it's because
they're shot really good they're shot in
shadow and they're shot you know in
close-up on specific aspects and
elements and it works really good but
then we start getting long lingering
shots of a bunch of them in bright
daylight and the the costume for that
while they good design
don't get me wrong but the limitations
of it become very clear under the under
the harsh light of day they when they
put them in wide shot in really bright
light where you can see everything you
suddenly realize how not great the thing
actually moves and that it can't lift
its arms any higher than this and that
it just kind of rotates the upper body
in a very awkward fashion like they knew
enough to shoot the front end in the way
to make the suit work and then I guess
they thought well we've sold it now we
don't have to worry about that anymore
and they just stopped bothering to try
and have it just do it with any nuance
and the second half it's just weird to
me so let's start easy our way towards
the tail end and the twist and that
thing that happened at the end so I was
gonna say spoiler warning but I've kind
of already been talking spoilers and you
should have seen the episode before this
anyway so here we go the fact that
orphan 55 is earth is something that I
am of a couple of different minds on the
first thing is that it is very I was
gonna say it's very Planet of the Apes
it's actually not it's very beneath the
Planet of the Apes and I make that
comparison for two reasons one to show
off my geek cred a little bit because
they realize where they are through
finding basically a subway station which
is how it's done in beneath the Planet
of the Apes and also to I make the
comparison because beneath the Planet of
the Apes is not as good as Planet of the
Apes and I feel like this is this
compares better to that one then to the
original Planet of the Apes which is a
stone-cold classic the general idea of
basically the human beings
wiping themselves out and whoever is
left becoming monsters it's not exactly
a new concept in sci-fi it's actually
very tried and true one it's kind of new
to Doctor Who about the closest thing
come is like the takla Fane and the
future kind from utopia and then sound
of drums last of the Timelords
but that was more a existential dread
and the the crushing pointlessness of
existence destroyed human beings and
cause them to become something else as
opposed to you know just straight-up
radiation and whatever else biological
who knows went on so it's it's sort of
tapping a slightly different area for
Doctor Who and doctor who has dealt with
this kind of mutation penguin God's sake
that's what the Daleks are for crying
out loud so it's not a new idea but it
is for Doctor Who a new idea to have it
be on earth and make that link now I
have glanced at the discourse going on
around this episode but a couple of
things I'm going to address the first is
anyone who's complained about this
somehow breaking the various things that
we've seen a future earth in other
episodes of Doctor Who there's a couple
of things I'm gonna say about that
preceding it was saying I don't feel
that that's the case and I don't have a
problem even if it kind of is and here's
why the first is we're not given a date
on this and I think that's kind of a key
thing there because other times we've
seen either horrible things happen to
the earth like with the end of the world
or the aftermath of horrible things
haven't happened to the earth like would
say the Beast below we're given some
dates some rock or as at least a century
in terms of where this lands that isn't
brought up here so the first thing to
keep in mind is that this could still
well fit into the same continuity where
the Beast below happens where the end of
the world happens where all the other
things place on future earth still
happens because that's a long timeline
and the earth could have been basically
new they say you know they say the word
nuclear winter yeah but the earth can
still at some point eventually recover
from that and especially if we're at a
point where human beings have left the
planet the human race hasn't gotten the
planets toast but the human race can
come back and and can't even mentions it
terraforming fixing it this is all
possible so I reject the argument that
this in any way negates any of the other
future things happening on earth that
we've seen and the other thing is we do
have a tossed off line from the doctor
about possible future alternate
timelines which she doesn't go into a
ton of detail which is good I think it
just was going to get to introduce that
idea or reintroduce that idea back into
this cuz it's worth bringing up the
doctor does talk about events can we
change timelines can be rewritten and we
don't see that in relation to the future
very often that's usually when the
doctor messes slightly with something
that's from the past and it's a lying
tossed off so that we don't have to deal
with the butterfly effect and ripple
effects of what was done in whatever
that earlier story was but if you
extrapolate out that does mean or
potentially could mean that some of the
future events are not fixed as well so I
think either option works whichever one
you're comfortable going with and so
that concern I just be gone with it but
let's talk about the thing
that's you know the thing I'm not gonna
make the complaint I think some people
expect me to given sort of some of the
complaints I had about the some of the
dialogue around the attitudes of men and
how women were treated in the last two
episodes and my last review I brought
some of that up in a negative manner and
I said it kind of felt like they were
just poking the bear I'm not gonna make
that complain about this because that
final speech from the doctor the
sentiment of it is 100% backed up and
relevant by the episode it's it fits
that that's the message of the episode
so it's not poking the bear any more
than the entire frickin thing was and
that's their core premise on this
episode so no I'm not gonna make that
complaint and also more to the point I
don't take issue with the message
it's a classic sci-fi future set message
we need to take care of the planet and
we don't really do it very well right
now
so cautionary tale time you know it's
plenty of the Apes that Soylent Green
it's lit this is this is very classic
sci-fi stuff so I don't have problem
with that and also frankly I agree with
this things are great and collectively
we're not doing enough to fix it yet
however I can agree with a message and
still disagree with the method by which
that method that message is delivered
because oh my god she practically turns
to look directly into the camera and say
here's the here's the message of this
story you just saw and it felt like I
was watching a Saturday morning cartoon
from the 80s it was like a little bit's
tacked on at the end of he-man or GI Joe
and now you know cuz knowing is half the
battle oh god it's just so Jar
and clunky and it's not the message the
message is the thing but like it's also
kind of insulting because the message
was really pretty obvious in the thing
already the instant they said it was
Earth and the doctor even just
offhandedly mentions you know you didn't
take care of the planet or whatever you
whatever the heck was said that's enough
the point is made and it feels insulting
it feels like let's make sure that these
people actually get the message here hey
let me tell you now what's actually
going on and I feel patronized is what I
feel like I feel like the show didn't
trust my intelligence and it's really
frustrating because I said that I would
come back to Bella and Ryan well here's
why because there is a very part of the
connection between the two of them is
their similar damage Ryan with his issue
with his dad Bella with her issue with
their mother that links the two
characters in a way that actually plays
off of it makes sense that they
connected as immediately they did it
makes sense that they sort of bond out I
mean granted there was an external
reason for them to do it but they sort
of bond over the you know which is a a
childhood protective thing that that you
know people can continue to do further
on into life and these things connect
them as characters in a way that is
really really well done and really neat
because it means we didn't have to sink
a ton of raw on runtime into sorting out
the ways in which they are similar and
the ways in which they connect that
simply gets laid out and it's clear for
anybody paying attention anyone who
knows anything about Ryan at all this is
so clear he doesn't have to say hey my
dad left me I'm like you
here's how we're similar you should
listen to me because he doesn't have to
cuz we get it and even if you don't know
or don't remember that about Ryan in the
performance you can tell there's
something going on and he sells that as
an actor and you can tell there's more
going on under the surface and maybe
it'll make you go back you know what was
that
but like it's there something is there
so this thing at the end is the
antithesis of that it doesn't just lay
it out and trust us to see it and if it
was a more subtle episode maybe I'd be
more forgiving of it but this episode
wasn't subtle and not even in a way that
I think was bad up until that last
speech but that last speech was a brick
to the face and like the only sort of
asterisks and proviso a put on this is I
think there is something to be said with
making your message so clear that it
can't be ignored I do think there's a
validity in that and I say that
especially as somebody who gets
incredibly frustrated I mean this is a
slightly different issue but just to
make my point it's incredibly frustrated
with creators be they writers be the
directors be they whatever who will say
that there are lgbtq+ characters in
whatever they've made but that's not
clear from the work themselves they'll
be like oh well no but that character is
but it's not clear and because it's not
clear people can ignore it and so you
know to use the obvious example I
remember what I did one of my videos
talking about Harry Potter and
Dumbledore supposedly being gay there
was a comment from someone who said I
have a friend who I had a conversation
with him who actually told me I know she
says Dumbledore is gay but because it's
in the books I'm not
to believe that because I don't want to
so there is a validity and I don't like
that I just had to use Harry Potter as
an example to give another stuff that's
gone on lately but look it was the
easiest one for me to grab so just roll
with me but there is a validity to being
so clear that you can't be ignored but
even allowing for that
it's just clunky it doesn't feel like
words she's saying to the companions it
feels like words she's saying to the
audience and the doctor can give a
lecture to the audience by proxy that's
what the the whole thing in the Saigon
inversion is and that was brilliant but
that still felt like something the
doctor would have said to the people in
that room this doesn't feel like a piece
of dialogue that anybody would just say
I I think I wish that it had been a
dialogue between the companions maybe
that would have worked better but like
to just have the doctor like I said
practically turn to camera and go the
moral of today's story boys and girls
it's just a horrible way to try and do
that so I'm just frustrated and I'm
actually more frustrated because I agree
with the message and like I said there
are even reasons why you can argue you
should be super blunt with it but even
allowing for that this doesn't work and
that frustrates me in a way that feels
very familiar because that was a big
part of the general manner which series
11 frustrated me because series 11 did a
bunch of stuff that I wanted the show to
do ditch the series arcs for at least a
season and no new the outdoor sorry no
returning monster
per season and like it did a bunch of
stuff that I wanted the show to do yet I
still didn't like that series very much
which was frustrated because I'm going I
don't like this buddy got core ideas
that I really enjoy and yet I'm still
not loving a lot of this and that's how
I ended up feeling in this episode that
was a reminder of that feeling that I am
the episode up until that point was
solid it wasn't great it wasn't terrible
it was solid had its ups and downs I was
having overall a good time maybe a
slightly unmemorable time but a good
time and then it gets to the end and
it's like I agree with what you're
saying but I am really annoyed with you
the way that you're saying it orphan 55
frustrating so that's my thoughts on
that one honey like look just don't
please don't get into fights in the
comments section like it's one thing and
I mean this sincerely it's one thing
when people attack me I actually get
really annoyed when people get in fights
with each other in the comment sections
especially when they turn nasty please
just don't and as long as you can obey
that you know drop down a comment let's
talk about it bunch of stuff to do like
subscribe patreon that would help and
all the usual stuff but you don't have
to do any of it because at the end of
the day you're the council I am just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is a jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]